[Musique]
cette commission d'enquête sur
l'efficacité des politiques publiques en
matière de rénovation énergétique est à
l'instigation du groupe écologiste du
Sénat je pense que c'est une très belle
et intéressante initiative plus
particulièrement bien sûr dans le
domaine de la rénovation énergétique et
dans le contexte actuel de sobriété
énergétique on peut chiffrer à plus de
12 millions de deux personnes je dirais
qui vivent dans des passoires thermiques
c'est à peu près 5,2 millions de
logements sachant que derrière ces
logements on a du logement privé on a
des bailleurs sociaux on a des bailleurs
publics on a des bailleurs privés et
donc forcément on n'agit pas de la même
manière sur de collectif sur de l'invite
de l'individuel il faut que nous
puissions présenter à nos concitoyens
des dispositifs qui soient plus lisible
plus simple
plus efficace que ceux qui existent
actuellement et surtout des dispositifs
qui s'inscrivent dans la durée et avec
une certaine stabilité on sait
qu'actuellement ces quatre à cinq
milliards d'euros qui sont affectés pour
ces pour ces politiques publiques par an
donc on voit qu'il y a une question
financière mais derrière ça il y a
comment réalise ces travaux et pour
réaliser ses travaux il faut des
entreprises il faut de l'ingénierie il
faut des architectes qui faisait bureaux
d'études il faut tout être
accompagnement et donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut à la fois aussi travailler
sur sur la filière comment on peut mieux
produire des matériaux plus locaux et
notamment des matériaux biosourcés il
nous faudra bien sûr mesurer qu'elles
peuvent être les répercussions des
rénovations énergétiques en termes de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre mais
aussi ce qui est important c'est comment
est-ce qu'on arrive à travers ces
travaux de rénovation énergétique à
apporter plus de confort à nos
concitoyens et à faire en sorte
également qui puisse en avoir un
bénéfice direct bien sûr en termes de
confort d'habitat mais aussi en termes
de pouvoir d'achat parce qu'il en va
effectivement d'une volonté d'atteindre
la stratégie nationale bas carbone d'ici